I'm a big fan of Nicholas Deorio. What can I say? You do your
research.
She's butch.
>> Sometimes I can't tell if you're an Ethan hater or a
fan. Most of the time you just post his W's. Is your Is your
lady wife also mentally impaired?
>> Did you look cute as [__] tonight?
>> I can't wait. I'm sorry. I can't wait. I just read the
text of the tweet. I can't wait. I'm sorry. I was going to wait.
I wanted to wait and not include it in the segment, but Nicholas
Deorio isn't impressed by Anisa Jomha's impersonation of Hila
Klein. Not only is that offensive, it's also bad. It's a bad
impression. It's not even a good impression. No way.
No way he goes with the cope they had. There's no way. Come on,
man. He He spent all this time. I thought he was kind of pulling
back from these people a little bit, and he just He jumps the
shark. There's no way. Hold Maybe the text is just wrong. Maybe
they're just You know what? I think the person who clipped this,
they they knew I'd watch it and they want to embarrass me by
like having me freak out about Nicholas Deorio saying these things.
I don't think the clip will actually say those things, okay?
Let's give it a look. I'm a big fan of Nicholas Deorio. What
can I say? You do your research.
>> Who's saying that Nicholas Deorio does good research?
So what? It's so good every time. I'm sorry. It's so [__]
I do a dono sound. That will be a new dono sound. You done?
Wait, that was the Hila Klein impression?
Listen, all right? In the time that we've we've seen Hila Klein
I mean, that just doesn't That's not like a teared.
I don't know. I know. Not only is that offensive, it's also bad.
Like it's a bad impression. I said I had one. Wait, why is it
inve- Why is it
Why is it Hold on. Why is it offensive?
That's racist?
Is Was there a part of that that was Israeli? That doesn't sound
like an Israeli accent. That's a accent, okay? There's no part
of that that's Israeli. It's just all That's my That's my Ela
impression. That sounds like a character from What's What character
is this from
from from The Simpsons?
>> I think it's Barney. It sounds like Barney from Is it
Barney? It's like the fat guy.
Oh, YOU THIS ACTUALLY OH, THAT'S a good one. She sounds like
the bear from The Cleveland Show. But you're saying Apu cuz she's
doing like a weird Everything she does sounds like a weird Muslim
accent, too.
Her only concept of accents is doing
You can't lie. The first time you watch it, you said she's really
good at encapsulating the Israeli accent.
Like a Muslim thing. Big fan of Nicholas Di Oreo. What can I
say? Well, actually a little Indian, maybe, too. Hey, you do
you. She sounds like she's about to explain why I need to join
Metro PCS with a new talk and text plan. research with full unlimited
data. Yeah, it kind of is the bear. I mean, this is not even
a good
Nick is going to make so much freaking money, yeah. Oh, no.
I don't think this sounds Israeli. I think it sounds nothing
like an Israeli accent. Ela doesn't sound Israeli to me when
she talks, except for Ethan. Ethan
>> the famous Ela impression. That was, yeah. It kills
at parties.
I had a poker event that I did that at, and it did kill. So.
Adrian That surprises me that they can actually house a party.
>> Like you're so mentally by Hila Klein that you actually
just do impressions of her at parties with your friends who are
probably Dude, HE'S SO MAD.
HE'S LIKE angry about this.
You're I'm surprised you guys can't even afford I'm surprised
you guys can't even have a party.
In your poor house.
You're so migrate by Hila Klein. >> Not online. I imagine
not online people. Wouldn't even really Yeah, what parties? Now
she's pretending to go to poker parties just like Hila. Oh my
Yeah, wait, that's a Dude, oh another
vicariously living through a [__] her friends thing.
Oh I Dude, I love these poker things. If only I got invited to
these poker events, yeah. Dude.
Dude. Oh,
come on.
Come on.
Okay, now unfortunately
this came out after the TweePy video, but now
now that we've watched that, we do have to go back and actually
watch the TweePy video, okay? TweePy did a video on this. Basically
saying the same things I'm saying, okay? Just calling people
out
who refuse to laugh who refuse to just laugh along. Just laugh
along. She got you. Just laugh along, right? Just laugh. It's
funny. You know, I make these videos, I offer my opinion, and
often times I say things you don't want to hear, okay? I just
do. I say, "Oh, you know what? This iDubbz arc, I like this iDubbz
arc. I like that he's going hard as [__] against
H3."
>> Hold on. He did tweet out the iDubbz arc. >> with
Ethan Klein. I'm terribly obsessed with Don't talk so much about
what you >> Hila Klein. Don't talk so much about what you
do. >> 20 what? 20 who? 20 how?
20 what? You seen something like this behind my back?
Why you sing?
20 who?
Oh, Ethan. Okay, Ethan. You know she's a supermodel. What What
do you mean stretch mark? Like a Papa John mama
Stretch mark. How does he know so much about the butt?
No. Poopy. Poopy and pee. my two favorite ingredients, too. I
think that's like a really dumb way to look at the If you ever
need a place to do something, you could always
collaborate with us. I don't know, I'm just throwing things.
Just spitballing.
>> I was raised by wolf.
She's flushed.
That's so [__] that. That's so
>> Return. Return.
Return. What are we doing? >> raised by wolf.
Yes, yes, yes, and more yes.
Dude, you look cute as [__] tonight.
If you saw a thousand [laughter] of these Dude, it's actually
so What the [__] >> coming at you like this
across the hill, yeah, you might retreat and come up with a plan
for Germany.
Uh
crazy, man. It's crazy. Okay, back to this back to this a little
>> Okay. You want You want to He doesn't even know what
to say. He's dumbfounded. Ela's covering her face in embarrassment.
These people are losing it. Because because the reality is it
was a very accurate portrayal of Ela Klein's voice. >> You want
to hear my impression of Nisa? Hi, my name is Anisa and I You
just did a silly voice.
Dude, this guy this guy
This guy belongs in like a military prison cell. I don't What
the [__] is wrong with this human being? Dude. >> Is
Dan half monkey? What the [__] going on here? Oh
my [__] god.
>> I hate Jewish people. We're just going to slip that
one in. We're just going to slip that one in. We hate what? What
What was that, Ethan? What are you We're
>> I'm stupid. I'm dumb. I hate Jewish people. Why? Why
would you say that, bro? If that was the only time they accused
people of anti-Semitism, actually Anisa of anti-Semitism during
the stream, maybe I could let it go. But, that's not the only
time. >> Oh, give the game away. If you hate someone, just
call them anti-Semitic.
This happens way too often. Way too often with these guys. And
the second you see it happen, you start to notice it more and
more. Every time somebody does something that's a little edgy,
that's against one of these people, they're not able to take
the joke. They don't know how to roll with it, and they "Feels
anti-Semitic."
>> You literally didn't say anything like her. You just
did a silly voice. So, here it is. Here it is. I know. I know.
>> really have to do this? Anisa said she's given me permission
to play it. Okay.
I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do the
research.
Dude, dude, close your eyes for a second. That's the Ela Klein,
okay? For about 5 seconds, Anisa was possessed by Ela Klein.
I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do the
research. [laughter]
You literally didn't say anything like her. You just did a silly
voice.
I feel like your coverage has been really good on topics that
I end up watching. Like, you're really
You're good with research. That in the end, what? Only like
You're good with the research. I Dude,
Okay, whatever Anisa was doing for an accent is not close. >> people
will be approved to work for and talk to and like hang out with
what? I don't understand. I got a tweet.
Ian, you still think anybody is scared of you? Like you making
no sense, brother. I'm a big fan of Nicholas De Oreo. What can
I say? You do your research. Do you have anything else to say?
Oh, she's got such a horse dog [__] Do you have anything
else to say?
I'm a big fan of Nicholas De Oreo. What can I say? You do your
research. Is she like part Swedish? Is that what it is?
She like got a sweet She got a part partially Swedish accent
going in there, >> Anissa Anissa is winning me over every
day. They told me to hate her. I love her. >> Anissa so
accurately mimicked Dude, I feel like the same way a little bit.
I'm like I never knew anything about Anissa, right? I knew people
hated her and and hated iDubbz, but I didn't know anything about
her. And then I see this clip and I'm like, dude, I have to give
like the caveats. Like I don't know anything about her. I don't
know how much she talked before this. I know people hate her.
They like say she ruined iDubbz's career or whatever, right?
I'm like I'm like having to give all of the caveats. And I just
want to say I like the clip. I just want to without caveat say
that's an awesome clip. That's a great clip. Ethan Klein's voice
that had no response. He became [__] like frozen
in time. And his only response
she must hate Jews. I hate Jews people. I think it's [__]
up that you would just accuse someone of anti-semit- Bro.
Oh, no. I I unfortunately I'm not going to undo it, okay? But
somebody linked the Willy Mac reply here. And unfortunately I
had already
this one.
Dude, Willy Mac show responds to this goes, "Sometimes I can't
tell if you're an Ethan hater or a fan. Most of the time you
just post these W's."
Is your Israeli wife also mentally impaired? [laughter]
Wait, is this how your Israeli wife sounds? I have a I have some
bad news for you, okay? You get some genetic tests done, there
might be something wrong, okay? You might not want to You might
need
to reconsider the kids. All right? It's [__] up,
but it's true. >> racism, like that's a big crime, and
the fact that you're just like willy-nilly throwing that around,
disgusting. But to say this about your wife's voice, Hi, my name
is Anisa, and I Hey, it's You just did a silly voice.
Why on earth would you ever call Ela's voice silly?
Okay? That's a human being. That's your wife. Do you have anything
else to say for your friends, though? The problem is >> The
problem is that she doesn't. That's the problem. >> That's
the problem. >> She She Who else do we want to burn today?
Who else do we want to burn today? Oh my god, Ela Klein, man,
she's always very transparent.
>> I just hate that he's acting like he still has something
up his sleeve, but he won't do it. He's too classy. He's not
going to go nuclear. Oh, wow, thank you, iDubbbz. Like we gave
a I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do the
research.
>> Oh my god. By the way, it needs to be said, Ela Klein's
been doing a show with Ethan Klein for the last 10 [__]
years, okay? She's never had a clip half as funny as Anisa on
her [__] second or third stream. You know, there's
Yes, well, Anisa technically streamed for a whole bunch of time
before that. That was her profession for a long time. But true,
yes.
Dude, Ela's like literally never been funny a single time. What
What's the funniest Ela clip? I can't even think of a funny Ela
clip, to be honest with you. The funniest Ela clips are the ones
I see on Red Bar, and Ela is not the one making those things
funny intentionally, okay? I'm sorry.
Those are The only times I've ever laughed at Ela Klein are when
Red Bar has her pictures up on his screen, okay? >> There's
been this There's been this Ethan Klein versus iDubbbz, Ian Jomha,
okay? There's been this this war brewing, but I think the real
war, the war I want to see is the war of the wives, okay? I want
to see Anisa versus Ela. I want to see it. Because I don't think
Ela's got it. I don't think Ela even, you know, you would think
an IDF soldier, okay, raider of Ramallah, would know what to
do when it comes to war time. But I think Anisa's got them gorilla
tactics, okay? Shut Bro, chill, man. What the >> Okay,
my heart goes out to you, Anisa. I'm very very proud of what
you've done today. Good Canadian girl. Good Canadian
>> I just Now we need to see more. Now I need this on the
daily. I need Anisa going at Ela every day. Something Something
that I don't think people have realized is that Anisa has been
the butt of the joke for 10-plus years. People have been saying
that she's the reason iDubbz has had his downfall, that he changed,
that she's making him into a cuck, all of that [__]
Dude, what are you going to
Unfortunately, like some of that There's some truth to some of
that stuff. That's the [__] thing.
But is that Anisa's fault or is that iDubbz's fault, okay? >> say
to an I'm not I'm not committed to liking iDubbz ever, okay?
I've never seen I Anytime I watch iDubbz, when he posted that
video of him crying at the end with the psychologist,
okay? But the person who broke him, I could be a fan. Anisa that
she hasn't already heard, okay? She knows. She's got it, okay?
Now, when she turns the tables and she decides to go after Ela,
what will Ela say? You You know You know play the classics. We
all heard them. We all heard them. Oh my god, I hope she turns
up the [__] temperature. And let me be clear, I've
I've made those videos. I've been the one saying that Anisa did
all this to iDubbz because she did. In In a Obviously, iDubbz
is his own man, he makes his own decisions, but let's not act
like Anisa didn't have a lot of influence in there. But now it's
Anisa's world, okay? It's her time. It's her time. [laughter]
Anyways, to end this video, I figured we should read some of
the comments underneath my
I, Anissa, should just stick to
>> I liked how Ethan copied the voice to make fun of her,
but seemed to realize it was actually really accurate, so quickly
switched to doing a different one. Good lord, how is copying
someone's voice anti-Semitic? These people are so sensitive.
You'd have to ask Ethan Klein. You'd have And now, you can ask
Nicholas DiOrio, cuz apparently Nicholas DiOrio also believes
that doing that voice was terribly anti-Semitic.
It's ask Ethan Klein. >> What? I tried watching this clip,
but when it came back to Ethan and Eli, I vomited. One of the
best impressions of all time. It honestly sounds like a bad Kermit
the Frog impression, which to be fair, is kind of what she sounds
like. I condemn the following tweet. I disagree with the following
tweet. This this tweet is up. I don't even think Ela sounds Israeli.
I thought she was just from New Brunswick. That is People from
New Brunswick are great. Don't ever say that, okay?
Oh, unfortunately Chleapy doing the same cope back in the other
direction.
I almost want to watch now one more time. I'm a big fan of Nicholas
DiOrio. What can I say? ONE MORE TIME.
>> SAYING THAT NICHOLAS DiOrio does good research is so
funny.
You don't know sound. That will be a new don't know sound. I'm
making it
You don't Wait, I thought it was offensive.
Wait, that was the Hila Klein
Listen, all right? In the time that we've we've seen Hila Klein
impressions,
I mean, that just doesn't That's not like a
I don't know. Not only is that offensive, it's also bad. Like,
it's a bad impression. I said I had one. That's my That's my
Ela impression. That's Not only is it offensive, it's bad. Why
is it offensive?
What's What character is They like so he he talks about a bunch
of characters that aren't even There's no stereotype attached.
>> This from
from from The Simpsons.
>> Well, I think it's Barney.
Apparently, people also say explicitly to Ela that she sounds
like Barney from The Simpsons.
Apparently, she has been told this directly that she sounds like
Barney
from The Simpsons.
All right, back to the Nicholas thing. And then we've got these
clips here, okay?
This Leia Sapienti person is the last person off the Nicholas
De Oreo train, I
I believe
Is this the person people say looks like a gorilla, yes? Am I
correct in this?
Am I correct in This is a whole bunch of paragraphs here, yeah.
I don't know what this is,
5:50:53.
I think this is a longer cut of the same thing. Anisa talks about
the new H3 podcast crew members and says that Tamara looks and
smells like pennies. Tamara's Jewish, by the way. LOL, not a
good look for for the person who claims she's morally righteous.
Ethan and Hila Klein and the H3H3 Productions crew talk about
Anisa's smells like pennies comment towards
Harley Morenstein is puzzled as to why Anisa doesn't take into
consideration her optics more and how she's received on her on
stream due to her controversial past comments and actions regarding
the Jewish community.
Oh my god, never mind. I'm not going to watch the whole thing.
Will we watch the the clip first? No. We'll do the clip first
and then we'll watch the H3 reaction, okay? I find it pretty
creepy how quickly the new H3 members, like Tamara and Morgan,
are so quick to start making fun of you and Ian. Morgan, especially,
because she seemed so normal, but then laughs the hardest at
Ethan or Dan making fun of you guys. That's not even I I love
a [__] who smells like pennies, okay? They're often
very kind and they collect trinkets and they're cool.
But, you have to ascend. She hasn't ascended yet. I think she's
very young.
Yeah, I feel like this is saying she doesn't I feel like this
is saying she's a stinky [__] that doesn't wash her
So, it smells like her period. I think that's That's Yeah, that's
what That's what comes to my mind.
Okay? That's what I hear when I hear that comment, okay?
Yeah, for real. She looks like she smells like pennies, yeah.
I am sorry, but what the [__] is that? Well, I I
That's what I wanted to say. This is what I This is what I wanted
to talk about. I cuz I thought about that. And right away I was
like, "Whoa.
Really went in on the
Dude, I I do think there's like a
And I don't use this term lightly, but there is like a
hard requirement
for people
to engage in some form of prophylactic anti-Semitism, okay? That
these people have like no immune system. They cannot handle like
anything that approaches anti-Semitism, such that like it's like
an allergy. Things that they can convince themselves seem kind
of like anti-Semitism, they immediately freak out. It's like
at some point
Like at what point
Jesus, I'm going to No, I can't I can't.
At what point do you just like say, "Okay, somebody's got to
call Harley a slur because he needs to understand what actual
anti-Semitism is." Not that you should because it's good, but
like he needs to He needs to know what actual anti-Semitism is
so he stops having this oversensitive
thing going on where he is just pretending like this is offensive
in some way. Like stop.
I'm so done with people saying anti-Semitism's on the rise, and
then this is the anti-Semitism. If you talk about anti-Semitism
being on the rise, so it's a huge problem, and then this is your
example of anti-Semitism?
There are actual There's actual anti-Semitism in the world.
I have a problem with it. You are a
if you ever invoke anti-Semitism over a comment like this. You
are just the whiniest on planet Earth. Shut up. And then I stopped
and I was like, let's
That would be so stupid. Like, how do you do all that? I mean,
I I understand like every step along the way like the Nazi sword.
There's always things and then it's like that Not the Nazi sword?
No! Not the Nazi the skulls and the sheep house and then Nazi
sword. Holocaust apology.
I know that's not That's not any Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's it's
misunderstood. So, if I were to misunderstand
this penny joke,
let's say I misunderstood, it's nothing. I've heard people say
things smell like pennies before. Is it descriptive that wasn't
related. >> True. But if you are you
and given [snorts] the context of every Respect my JN. Respect
the fact that I'm that I'm going through a tough time right now.
What if I took this as anti-Semitism even though it's not?
What the [__] are you saying? everything in the past
year and given the swastika
then this joke >> I was too far away from that.
Dude. Given the swastika sword and where we are in the current
world, guys, given all of these incredibly anti-Semitic
pennies before as a descriptive that wasn't Jewish related. >> listen
again. But if you are you
and given the context of everything in the past year and given
the swastika
She's not said anything that remotely
I What is the context of the past year? You're just making things
up. You're literally just making things up.
Dude, it's [__] insane. >> then this joke
hits like that. It hits wrong right
And if you were slick, you would know to not say it and say something
else because you don't want to let people think that's what the
joke was unless you did. You don't want them to think that's
what the joke was.
Like, this is by the way, everybody should call this out cuz
this is the exact kind of thing that raises anti-Semitism. I'm
sorry. People will tell you there's nothing that excuses anti-Semitism,
but this does actually. This actually does excuse it, okay?
I'm so like getting canceled if anybody ever clips this [__]
but like this is No, Har- Harley has incurred some anti-Semitic
debt that he that needs to be paid forward to him. Not by anybody
in my audience, I'm not advocating anything. Do not go do that.
I will ban you from everything. If you were to do something like
that, if I were to say this and you were to go say something
to him in a way I could track back to you, you are nuked from
Discord, from the chat, both chats, okay? You're nuked from everything.
You can't do it. Okay, I'm just saying hypothetically.
It's so [__] annoying seeing this stuff happen. I'm
so done with people trying to
They're They're just always trying their hardest to make you
shut up. And like, don't don't make a joke. What if I What if
I maybe thought that was anti-Semitic?
Like, given a whole bunch of things that are totally unrelated,
what if I thought you were being anti-Semitic here?
Dude, what? >> And then it makes me think about the Tana
thing and I'm like, her idea for
if she did it with this type of execution brain is she would
have just gone to TanaCon and called Tana the N- and that's all
she would have done.
Dude, like they actually have made this person just a total character
picture in their heads.
And he says not that dangerous, guys. She's not that scary. I
trust me, she's >> out. You're not allowed to cry. So,
what? Like, that's the latent
dis- violent anti-Semitism that is oozing off of these people.
If you can't see it, then
we're basically just going I mean
where are we going? It feels like where it was during the war
and the Holocaust. And the Holocaust. It's just it's reminiscent
of that time.
My EPS my A human skull is in the mail. >> My It's Nazi
sword. My bill here.
Ethan and Hila just tipped $5.
There's the Ethan Klein Nazi sword clip.
Hold it in such a way that it's perfectly visible. Now, let me
ask you guys something. Am I a crazy Jewish Zionist freak that's
just like obsessively having delusions and is crazy and sees
anti-Sem Hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. >> Is a Zionist freak Hold on.
Hold on. Now, let me ask you guys something. Am I a crazy
a Zionist freak that's
>> just like obsessively having to Yes. Delusion.
Is crazy and sees Yes. The anti-Semitism everywhere? Yes. Or
are these guys doing a absolutely obvious dog whistle using a
I mean, two things can be true.
I think point B.
>> Hold it in such >> I could ever by the way, the
most I could ever give away on this
they looked at it and were like, "Oh, it'd be really funny if
you like crashed out about this." And then you gave them precisely
what they wanted.
All these people are like clearly anti-racist. They're They're
like not going out here and trying to be anti-Semitic in any
way. Right?
At at best, they were like, "Oh, I bet this would really irritate
him." At best, that's it.
I don't even believe that. I don't believe that they would do
that, to be honest with you. Items have sacrificed way too much
being woke to give it away for a Nazi sword. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. That's just facts. Anyway, where were we? There would
have been nothing else to which she has this she has this provocative
angle that she thinks, but it's like half-baked
and not thought out. And I actually think E Uh Harley just said
that if
apparently that if Anisa went to TanaCon,
like iDubbbz did, she would say the hard R, apparently. >> is
better
Pull up a photo of Tamara. She does look like she stinks. Okay,
we're going to chill on that. >> bad joking than she is.
>> Busted. So, she shouldn't be in this space winging it,
saying whatever they want on camera, cuz all you're doing is
paying the bills of those two guys, those two Canadian guys that
are always yelling about you.
>> Those two Canadian guys are going to be yelling about
somebody else pretty soon. I can feel it. I can feel it. I am
going to wish it into reality.
PPP, PPP, if you can hear me, please, please, PPP.
Do an episode on Ethan Klein. Do an episode on this awful podcast,
okay? PPP, if you can hear me, maybe even Warski, but PPP, if
you can hear me,
Please. Literally, you have to you have to This is so embarrassing,
okay? always freaking out, like you're paying
the triangle that she You pay
They don't know they know not what they do, okay? They know not
what they summon. Those guys are Those guys are making They're
our YouTubers that literally make money off the fact that you're
not good at that. And now now look what's going on here. Now
it's like I'm actually here, and I actually have And I've met
you, and I have to be like, I wonder if that was a triangle on
purpose
in some sort of nefarious intelligent way, or was it just so
foolishly careless? Yeah. Either way, it's not even paying a
single bill. So, what the [__] are you doing? Right.
[clears throat] Why why even risk being misconstrued as anti-Semitic
for nothing? And you know what's
Because negotiating with you people would be worse than negotiating
with Hamas, okay? You people are the real terrorists and you
won't prevent any of the rest of us from enjoying life. crazy
she did this after
in her first stream she had this story about how Ethan and I
show up late to the podcast and then leave.
>> These people suck so badly.
It's actually insane to me how badly these people suck. Like
I'm actually losing it.
They they
They're the [__] worst, okay? >> Right after
so we have no soul.
She said that we have no soul. >> Oh, I'll pull that. I'll
pull that. We got that. >> people also pointed that that
is racist.
Like making people seem inhumane
and and less than
is you know it's it's that's the things that they do. So after
she already said that on the first stream now on the third stream
she's saying to Mars smells like pennies.
Mhm. Yep. It's just a little bit much. >> are painted as
evil, if you're evil people, then they could say whatever they
want about you even if it's so [__] up because they
have painted you as evil. Dude, I swear to God I used to feel
like a ton of empathy for Ethan Klein. I used to feel like a
ton of like I just felt like he was, you know, understandably
upset and was not getting a lot of charity from other people.
I felt so much empathy for this guy
And it's just so it's so crazy that this is where we are. And
once you're literally evil, anything bad could be said, anything,
whatever they want because that's evil and it's good versus
Uh what would you say about labeling people racist and anti-Semites?
Do you think a lot of people like really hate racist anti-Semites?
Do you think people really care? Do you
What what's a word you would use to call somebody an anti-Semite
that's like inflammatory?
Would be like Nazi?
What do a lot of people, you know, liberals, left-wingers think
you should do with Nazis? Maybe punch a Nazi? Like can we not
at all use our brains to see that you're going the exact same
direction with Anisa and you don't seem to give a [__]
at all?
I don't I don't know. It just doesn't even click a little bit.
There's no There's no spark there. There's no light on. >> people
in their brains or whatever narrative they're trying to spin
up. Someone mentioned um an alternate explanation explanation
for the penny reference could be menstrual blood, which is I
guess Sorry about that. Uh misogyny. So, it could be anti-Semitism
or misogyny. You can pick Take your pick.
Um Either way It's not misogyny. If you don't clean that [__]
out If you bleed, okay? You don't clean that [__]
out. It's gross. >> Wait, I've never heard anybody say
that, too. Like, what kind of >> It sounds like you're
like You smell like a penny, Jew girl. That's what it sounds
like. What are we talking about? >> That's that's how I
That's my first >> why This is what happens when you coddle
this kind of behavior. I am I'm going to double down on my current
quest, okay? That when people are being like overly neurotic,
I do not have patience. I just immediately call it out. You are
self-victimizing. You are embarrassing yourself. Everybody here
is like laughing at you behind your back, okay? They all think
you're [__] embarrassing. This is how I handle it
every time now. Every single time. The second it starts, I go,
"You are embarrassing yourself. Everybody's laughing at you.
Shut the [__] up, okay? Do not let these people Do
not give Do not give your empathy to these people. They're empathy
vampires. They will take it all, okay? They will take it all
from you and then they will keep asking you to make
Just cut cut the cord immediately. Just be like, "You're embarrassing
yourself. This is sad. This is tragic. Shut the [__]
up, okay?" >> you mean, she smells like pennies? Like,
what what? What is she, like 90 years old? What kind of insults
are these? You smell like pennies. >> That's like a deep
level like uh Steven Crowder level of Velvetine eyes. Yeah. Like
my anti- old old-timey racism. Also, why is she playing about
smells considering her husband? >> It's like >> surprised
she can smell anything after that assault on her nostrils 24/7.
Remember Remember You want to talk about stinky, they made a
move your stinky ass husband to the door. >> Not stinky.
>> Exactly. To get a fresh wash.
Anyway, so interesting, hey?
These guys [__] suck at this.
I don't understand how they I assume it was better than this
at some
I assume it like was funny at some
To be fair, Ian and Anisa do look smelly. They do. Those tattoos
look smelly as [__] okay? You see somebody with those
trashy tattoos, those $5 tattoos, that person looks like they
stink, okay? Takes one to know one. >> I've never met her
though. So, she's saying I look like that. And also, I've literally
never I I I can't be I shouldn't be streaming.
I shouldn't be streaming. I just shouldn't be streaming. I just
shouldn't be streaming.
This looks like our friend Zed, doesn't it? I
I just see a similarity here with I've I've literally never said
anything about her ever. I was just thinking [laughter] I I was
like I don't think that you've ever even talked about that. So,
So, she's making like
Yeah. And I probably haven't I mean
>> Somebody get the Cybertruck right now. Somebody get
the Cybertruck right now. I think there's something inherently
different I'm sorry, the Cybertruck. The Cybertruck thing doesn't
even work, to be honest with you. I'm just saying. I I look stinky,
I guess. You do look, right? Like if she doesn't know if she
doesn't Oh my god. Thank you, Ela. I didn't want to say it. I
couldn't say it, Ela. Thank you so much. Oh, that's a weight
off of my chest. Thank you, Ela. I didn't want to say it, listen,
okay? Thank you, Ela. I wasn't allowed to. I got there for me.
Yeah, and I probably haven't I mean I think [snorts] I think
there's something inherently different about you that she doesn't
like. I look stinky, I guess. I mean, you you do look right?
Like if she doesn't know if she doesn't know a lot about you,
what's the first thing she would know from looking at you is
probably considering the things they care about.
What? Did you wait wait harder there than I thought she was going
to? Jesus [laughter] Christ.
Holy sh
You know
If I say if I knew nothing about you, I can immediately see that
you're you are like loudly in my visual field, loudly okay? Everything
about you okay, just so you know. Just so you know.
I was going to say I don't think I've ever said anything about
that. I might have like laughed at something you guys >> They're
like, "Oh, I heard her laughing in the background."
So, it's this weird thing and I think it's the snark overall
that like they want us to leave, but also they hate the new people
because they know, you know, the new people are they're they're
very vocally they're new here. They're so very supportive. They're
very vocally they're very you know, they're helping us save money.
They look like they are, you know
you know, they're fiscally responsible people perhaps involved
in drawing up contracts. I don't know what how to say the all
the new staffer is All the new staffer is So, the snarkers hate
them and they're they're more likely to participate
for whatever reason with certain discussions, you know what I
mean? Like They didn't work with Hassan. They didn't they weren't
here for certain things. So, it's makes more sense that Nate's
just going off. It's less awkward for him. Um so, it's this weird
thing where they hate the new people for being full so supportive
and they hate us for still being here. So Jesus Christ. Okay,
that was a rough rough
rough segment.
My god, man.
Jesus. That was crazy. Man, we got all that from just that little
hour-long segment. Let's [__] go. Let's go.
All right.